الجفاف عنوان المشهد هنا في سد سيدي
البراق شماليه تونس واحد من 37 سدا في
مختلف انحاء البلاد انحصر مخزونها بشكل
كبير نتيجه موجه الجفاف وندره الامطار
للعام الثالث على التوالي
مشهد ثاني يعكس عمق الازمه هنا في هذه
الحقول
فالامن الغذائي للتونسيين لم يعد كسابق اذ
يحذر اتحاد الفلاحين من ان موسم حصاد
الحبوب سيشهد انخفاضا في المحصول نتيجه
شحن الامطار
خطر يستشعره محمد المزارع الشاب الذي يعمل
جاهدا لتخفيف تداعيات قله الامطار على
مشروعه الزراعي
حاجات ياثر علينا برشا في كفلاحه والحاجه
السدود
ثم ابار نقص المياه متاحه
كفاحه في الزراعات
وسعيا لمواجهه الازمه قررت السلطات قطع
المياه الصالحه للشرب 7 ساعات يوميا في
جميع ارجاء البلاد وحذر استعمالها في بعض
المجالات
وتتراوح عقوبات المخالفين بين الغرامات
الماليه والسجن لكن ثمه من يصف القرارات
بالمنقوصه التوجه نحو تحليه مياه البحر
لكن هذا الخيار مكلف جدا الاقتصاد التونسي
النقطه الثانيه اعاده استعمال المياه
المعالجه والمياه الصرف الصحي واعاده
ادراجه في الدوله الاقتصاديه للاستعمالات
الغير بشريه النقطه الثالثه مراجعه شامله
لطريقه حوكمه المياه في تونس والنقطه
الرابعه هي مراجعه ثقافيه لطريقه تعامل
التونسي بصفه خاصه مع الموارد المائيه
اثرت مواسم الجفاف المتتاليه في معظم
المجالات التي تعتمد على المياه كما
تراجعت الحصه السنويه للفرد باكثر من
النصف مقارنه بالمعايير العالميه تحديات
تتطلب براي خبراء تغيير السياسات المائيه
المتبعه منذ عقود لمواكبه التطورات نقص
حاد في هطل الامطار للعام الثالث على
التوالي ونظوب للسدود يهدد التونسيين
بالجفاف والعطش عوامل تزيد من المخاطر
التي تحدق بالامن الغذائي في ظل وضع
اقتصادي واجتماعي متازم اصلا سيف الدين
الجزيره تونس